les jours où nous avons deux guerres à
terme neiges je fais ultra malheureux au
haka staline est de retour il a chopé
une cure de rhinopharyngites dans la
nuit et west ham à ce qu'on essaye
compath aux malades
bonjour ne vais pas là pour parler de ça
c'est parti cette fois nous avons accès
au buste de lénine
on peut maintenant caresser les ai donc
c'est au carré si on va vers lui
on va pas commencer à accepter cela je
disais si on caresse le bouton avec le
but zelenine ça mais a encore ça mais
plus la pression et demie r&d ta vérité
il descend tout seul ça marche bien
mieux ça marche bien mieux on leur met
la pression avec les neininger avec les
ninjas non mais qu est le bras tu
descends énormément je suis outré nike
du snack pardon je me suis trompé de
dictateur regardez regardez comme ils
descendent tout seul c'est abusé mon
gars et si au piège d'un cheveu
crânement bats les couilles je vais tuer
quelqu'un c'est peut-être beaucoup plus
efficace mais [ __ ] qu'est ce que je
dois qu'on pense aux gardes
bah ça fait sursauter j'ai pas utiliser
le grade mais c'est simple le crâne toi
je le prends ça dégage non mais c'est
abusé avec toi ça recule vraiment pas
quoi je faisais utiliser le crâne âgées
théorie en fait c'est peut-être médaille
en fait je pense que plus je porte le
crâne qui est quand même lourd c'est un
gros canard grâce à vous les unes plus
en gros j'ai mal aux bras donc plus mon
bras tombe donc en gros faut vraiment
que je prenne le crâne que quand je veux
mettre la pression ensuite je leur pose
je garde pas dans ma main je pense que
ça vient de sa voyez là ça descend pas
trop aux plages de lâche et je refais
humain peut je pense que c'est ça qu'il
faut faire un gros tube à terre le crâne
trop longtemps quoi [ __ ] tout cas je
peux vous dire que l'aîné il avait tout
il avait la grosse tête
excellent et voila voila quand se calme
qu'on m'a appelé à une possibilité on y
arrive mieux on devrait préparer nos
plans pour le rush final au plus tard
pitié mettez pas tous les éléments au
puy à la mouche qui va se ramener à est
c'est parti ça commence allez on y va à
l'om est pas manquer il met pas manquer
ok nice attention ah ok les ninjas
besoin de ton crâne de minutes voilà
comme ça l'horloge recul
vite un [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] wave un
couscous je veux pas de job merci dieu
ça dégage à la mouche 11e fait stresser
alors je tiens la tête de lénine qui
fait 200 kilomètres tellement dans la
merde de stendhal et toi et continu
continu sur une loi ou tout fait mouche
de ce pays doivent être tués
voilà ça c'est une menace de deux puces
au karpaty matelas lampes en attend ça
sauve le nid de la bouche et dans la
langue c'est sale astuces dégage omerta
chante on paniquait non non non ça je
voulais ça dégage c'est ça alors hop
oui on n'est pas facile ou lymphomes
saga de la catastrophe mais vient de
m'appeler je viens de raccrocher tu as
un gars tu vas laisser profiter il faut
le plus c'est paul beeston recherche de
main au combat et que je fais juste avec
l'idée en amoureux on terminera cette
mission en amoureux tranquillement à
pourquoi ce niveau est impossible voilà
pendant qu'il ya pas encore téléphone
qui sonne la meuf qui veut conjuguer
voila voila l aime bien ça tient depuis
halo super merde hockey lna
j'ai besoin de toi non mes mecs abuse
pas là dans là je suis en amour avec
lénine tu me laisses oh [ __ ] j'ai
arrêté de jouer quoi
[ __ ] de bouche mon gars c'est pouvait
tout est dans ma pipe et et est brûlé en
même temps que le tabac là ça fait du
bien ok je comprends ça je prends ça tu
lui
je repose je prends téléphone je répond
j'ai pu te raccroches vie tu raccroches
vie tu raccroches très vite je peux pas
je peux pas je peux pas tu la plage du
lama plastoc lors qu'il faut que leur
recul ok c'est bon alors oui achetions
ce sujet vont bien ok c'est bientôt la
pin up [ __ ] qu'ils soient débloqués
encore au doigt de tamponner de la bonne
couleur pour augmenter l'intégrité de
l'état
mais arrêtez arrêtez ça fait trop on a
pas mal de chien à tamponner sur les
papiers importants
je devrais vraiment avoir une sur terre
pour faire ce genre de travail les
weppes luttes intestines des années bush
dans son bureau mais si en plus tu vas
n'importe quoi on en est là quoi on est
là maintenant autant pomme ça veut dire
que notre main droite faudra qu'on lâche
la pipe des x pour prendre le holà là
c'est la galère à la sarthe ou que je
mette en verre
ok la peep [ __ ] de merde juste la peep
le bouton elle est en procès perdu un
génie regardez le crawler on a eu chaud
c'est là où le bus de lénine vague grave
nous servir mon gars ont fait reculer
l'heure plus que ça ok nous sommes plus
forts que jamais encore un petit peu et
nous seront les gagnants jour 18 je suis
à bout de force je suis à bout de force
j'en peux plus oh bordel de merde aux
puces et la mouche
olala aulas est nommé grand l'oeil de
toi aussi je peux déjà plus à tanger en
tout cas validé à temps ok c'est bon
maire qui s'est passé dans vos cerveaux
cas où je me suis dit j'ai eu au
téléphone à pure sur ce bouton c'est ça
va être très très dur et vu la lenteur
avec laquelle défilent le temps je pense
que ces derniers niveaux d'ailleurs la
l'op
ok ces mots le temps s'écoule tellement
lentement mais c'est pire que deux
heures de philo bien la bouteille vient
là ça va ça va papa prends soin de toi
oh [ __ ] les gars là mêle à la fois
d'un vrai leader que vous réussir quoi
lavagna que staline qui peut gérer ce
niveau on n'est qu'à la moitié avec
tellement scandaleux ok rapidité
efficacité la peep où il affirme je vois
plus rien avec cette femme petite école
je vois plus rien d'un ghetto que je
prenne ça ça allait de mon stress
ok c'est bon alors j'attends qu'on a
fait en même temps tu ta mais le mec qui
sait tout faire 20 je joue avec le plus
de lénine et a indiqué dans ce que je
dis mais là vraiment au nom mais je
viens de raccrocher c'est pas procès je
suis là est ce qu'on a gagné
est-ce qu'on a galaga ou pas non ça va
être plus dur je pensais ça allait tuer
quelqu'un dans la foi way arrête de
clignoter qui a level compéter on a
gagné on a filmé l'histoire on a
déverrouillé le mode sans fin se dire
qu'on a gagné
non il reste à des niveaux le moment est
venu de terminer cette gamme fois pour
toutes
l'ennemi avant cela nous devons rester
fort aujourd'hui la victoire sera
[ __ ] [ __ ] je me rase pour cette
bataille c'est bon je suis prêt au
[ __ ] pas mais l'erreur on gagnera la
guerre c'est tout simple attaque au hall
dernière ligne droite
les soldats se dotera de français on est
en train de gagner du territoire c'est
là qu'il faut y aller les nuls c'est
l'art lénine staline pardon tu veux la
paix il faut que je me la faites vite il
faut que tu as un regard sur la femme et
un de mon dieu je contrôle plus du tout
mon bras c'est chaud mon gars d'en face
à une minute de la fin
est-ce qu'on va gagner la guerre soyez
lagarde attend on a tout donné et c'est
une victoire
merci merci
on l'a fait en tant que petit père des
peuples à pourquoi pas mon visage bien
joué à portel attend intégré titulo quoi
tu avais pas d'annoncé à toulouse quand
on gagne la guerre alors que alors qu'on
a perdu
et voilà l'ancien fin de cette vidéo de
cette dernière vidéo sur cadeyrn staline
j'espère sera plus ces cas n'hésitez pas
à belém do kahn avait tu dois gagner une
carte recense aujourd'hui j'ai senti
votre énergie vous m'avez envoyé
tellement jean guy damas et sangoku
c'était super beau en plus aujourd'hui
on fait il bossait avec 40 minutes avant
je vous dis on est bien là alors ce trou
au bar du coin avoir un peu de vodka a
très vite